Hi everyone. I'm out of the country, but
I'm about to head back in the morning
because tomorrow night, the Seek and
Share Truth Apologetics and PMICS
conference starts in Ohio. If you'd like
to join us, that'll be Thursday, Friday,
Saturday, and Sunday in Ohio. We've got
tons of presentations. We've got some
debates on Sunday, but there's me,
there's John McCrae, Hatun, Vocab,
Anthony Rogers, and a bunch of others.
So, if you'd like to join us, the link
is in the description box. You'll need
to uh you'll need to sign up. Tickets
are free. Um, speaking of free tickets,
the organizers of the conference, that's
L and Eric and a couple of others, they
put it all together and they're
crowdfunding the costs of the conference
so that they can keep it free for people
who want to uh come, but that's a lot of
costs just in plane tickets and lodging
and so on. So, we don't want to leave
them stuck with the bill. So, uh, if you
can if you can go to the link in the
description box to donate to the
conference. That way they uh they make
back everything they put into the
conference so that they're not paying
for it themselves. All right, hope to
see you there. And if you can't attend,
please contribute anyway. Catch youall
later.